Next, let's dig into talking about some post-process volume properties that you can edit.
And first we'll talk about exposure adjustments versus raw.
So you can create an auto exposure, but adjust its range to keep it in the min max.
So if you see here, we've got some exposure settings on our post-process volume and you
have this min EV100 and max EV100, which you can use to clamp some values.
And you can also adjust it under the lit menu inside your editor.
If you click on lit and go down to game settings, you can tick that or untick it.
And then you also have a slider here to compensate for the exposure in this section here.
You can also do exposure adjustments and visualize them in the editor.
So if you want to visualize the adaptation under show, go to HDR eye adaptation.
So you click show at the top here and then go down to visualize and then HDR and you
can preview that eye adaptation.
And then you can also preview the depth of field in your shots as well.
So a cinematic depth of field, green is the foreground, black is the focus object and
then blue are any of the background objects.
So we've got a procedural diaphragm simulation.
So that means that the control, this controls a number of diaphragm blades, which is the
iris to directly influence bokeh shape.
And then aperture can be as small as desired, but has a maximum based on lens size, which
is your f-stop.
The aperture does not control light intensity so that you don't have to continually adjust
the exposure.
So you can see this depth of field diagram here where if you want a shallow depth of
field, you want a large aperture.
If you want some deep depth of field, you want to really narrow that aperture and make
it quite a small source that the light can get through there.
And then to touch upon the use of path tracer when working with depth of field.
In the past versions of path tracer, there was a major issue with translucency and depth
And the problem was that the translucent material wouldn't render to the depth buffer.
So essentially you weren't getting accurate depth of field.
So in the path tracer settings now, you can remedy that by the tick box here.
So reference depth of field.
And if you enable that, that will fix any legacy issues that you may have had previously.
And to close out, there's many different documentation.
So if you've heard anything in the previous few slides that you think you want to know
more about, maybe you want to know more about open color IO or any of the post process effects,
any rendering topics, you can find all the documentation here.
And these slides were put together by Sean Rod and Cami.